this morning communities in Ohio are
under a mandatory evacuation order after
a dramatic freight train to Roman
officials say around 50 cars some
carrying hazardous material derailed in
eastern Ohio causing this massive fire
it's been burning since Friday and there
is a high probability of an explosion
that could release toxic gas into the
air Jessica Gray of our Pittsburgh
affiliate KDKA is there Jessica good
morning
good morning Nate police issued that
mandatory evacuation last night and say
failing to do so could result in arrests
that's because they don't want to take
any chances and say that shrapnel from
any explosion could reach as far as a
mile from the crash site
we are at a risk now of a catastrophic
failure of that container a drastic
change in temperature inside one of the
toppled rail cars prompted that
emergency warning late last night this
catastrophic failure will if it occurs
it will produce hydrogen chloride and
phosgene gas into the atmosphere we need
you to leave
now
since Friday the Flames continue to burn
out of control from the Heap of rail
cars tossed across and on top of each
other I just could not fathom
all the fire
about half of the 100 cars from this
freight train traveling from Madison
Illinois to Conway Pennsylvania derailed
Friday creating this massive Blaze I
went outside on the porch and looked and
you see flames shooting about 20 feet in
the air the cause of the crash is still
under investigation but Federal
investigators with the NTSB say a
preliminary review says two videos show
a mechanical issue with the rail car
axle we're working to identify which
rail car experienced the potential
mechanical issue for further examination
a authorities say at least 20 of those
cars were carrying hazardous chemicals
so far east palestine's mayor says the
town's air and water quality are safe
and the state's environmental agency
would remove any contaminants from
nearby streams but the lingering pungent
smell in the air are giving some concern
is it safe for everybody to go back home
is it safe to be anywhere within the
blocked off area
officials say while most people in the
evacuation Zone have left more than 500
have not all schools and offices in the
village are closed today the governor
has deployed the National Guard here
over those growing concerns about a
potential explosion Gail
all right Jessica thank you very much